this week on brian ross investigates
the never before told story of
corruption the mob
and murder plots against the mayor of
one of the country's
biggest cities i was really lucky to get
out of there alive
at the age of 31 denis kucinich was the
youngest mayor of a major american city
taking on powerful interests who wanted
control of the municipal power company
and wanted him out of the way in a new
book
guccinis describes how he survived plus
the latest on the criminal investigation
of the trump organization
could the former president face
indictment this summer
as the manhattan district attorney has
begun to call witnesses
for a grand jury it's likely to be very
bad for donald trump
mr trump calls it a political witch hunt
and predicts he'll be back in office
soon
we're going to take back the white house
and sooner than you think
we'll get the inside story from pulitzer
prize winning
investigative reporter david k johnston
the racketeering charge
could put donald in prison for the rest
of his life if a judge were to sentence
in
prison and this week's winners and
losers in the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of media heights
this whole thing about the border we've
been to the border
we've been to the border you haven't
been before
from the law and crime trial network
this
is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live
i'm brian ross and tonight my colleague
rhonda schwartz is on assignment
we begin with the never before told tale
of corruption
powerful interests and mafia hits all
towed by the man who was at the time the
youngest mayor ever of a major
american city dennis kucinich of
cleveland
his amazing tale is in his new book out
this week the division of light and
power i covered kucinich as a young
reporter in cleveland it was the 1970s
and as recounted in the movie kill the
irishman
the mafia was flexing its muscles
inside rabbi rudolph rosenthal
characterized burns as
no saint but he said the numbers figure
had much charity and was often generous
and had many dennis kucinich welcome to
our program i have to say but for the
incest
your book reads like a modern day
version of chinatown
were you up against powerful
corporations
lobbyists corrupt police a corrupt city
hall
and the cleveland mafia yeah
i i i was really lucky to get out of
there alive
uh during that time uh you talk about
shots fired into your home right there
in that house
yeah right uh right behind me uh on the
one on the left there was i
powered rifle shot that uh that went
through
the place where i was sitting and had i
not
moved a split second earlier would have
uh it would have hit me
in the head and uh you know i i can tell
you that
you know one of the aspects of the story
is this undercurrent of
violence uh which i never talked about i
mean the book is the first time
i have ever discussed what was going on
because you know when you're in
office and you know you're a target you
got enough people that might be coming
after you without uh
talking about the the pros who are out
where ought to get you
dennis's campaign aides first of all
proclaimed him the winner of tonight's
election and the next mayor of cleveland
dennis kucinich was the boy mayor of
cleveland from 1977
until 1979 to say that his tenure as
mayor was turbulent
is an understatement were you at the
time the youngest mayor of the major
city uh
in america who were you making so angry
and why
well the big issue and that the book is
about
uh the title the division of light and
power is really about cleveland's
municipal electric system
and there was a long effort to
sabotage that system and to take it over
by the
private utility seeking a monopoly and i
was standing in the way
and what i learned later on from police
officials is that my
my stance on on protecting that light
system
uh among other things drew the attention
of organized crime
and uh you know it was one of those
issues that was
involved in assassination
planning the people voted to keep their
power plant
while it cost their mayor his political
career
knowing what you know now and maturing
the way you have
do you think you might take the same
stand principles don't change with time
it's really a matter what's inside of
you i did what was right for the people
at the time and if people today say i
was right i'm glad they do
yet you say at the end you have no
regrets and you won the day
well you know i mean it look life goes
on i
my approach to life is that i don't i
don't have hard feelings towards anyone
but
this story is important because people
need to know
what goes on what goes on behind the
scenes in a big city the kind of forces
that can drive it
and what happens when one person in this
case the mayor and it was me
will take on the very forces that think
that you know they run the city
regardless of who the people elected
so this um yeah
there absolutely are risks that one
takes
when you challenge the status quo from
inside city hall
but just as insidious i think in your
book is your description of how
bankers and corporate officials sought
to undermine your efforts
to reform the city hall look uh
you know people think they know where
city hall is
i found out that city hall was in the
boardrooms of banks of utility
monopolies of uh
of major corporations of the mob and all
these interests are used to
running city hall in their uh in their
financial to their financial benefit
and so um you know when i was elected i
wasn't a novice but
you know as a young mayor i think people
just expected that they could
that'd be a pushover and when i said no
you can you can say no very softly like
no
but when you say no and these interest
groups are so used to
getting a yes hear that they go well
wait a minute
and so their reaction can be very
powerful
headlines throughout the media broadcast
the battle between the kucinich
administration
and privately owned cei over who would
own the city's municipal
power plant but people elected me you
know that's who i
accounted for and the big issue was the
light system there was an attempt
to steal the municipal electric system
and i stood in a way i was the only
person standing in the way they needed
my
signature it wasn't going to happen
and you actually write that the big
utility that wanted
the municipal system caused blackouts
purposely
absolutely i mean it's a it's actually a
matter of
federal court records and the and
federal investigations
they cause blackouts on the system in
order to cause the public to lose
confidence in the system
they'd go into the neighborhoods after
the blackouts and ask communitylight
customers to sign up with their
firm saying hey looks like your light
system isn't working very well
i mean it's really like a mob related
tactic you know
you got a nice place here you know you
want to keep it that way
and so sign up with us and take our
electricity won't have any problems
they were creating blackouts on the
system and and you know the
uh the cover of the book is instructive
excuse me the cover of the book is
instructive in that regard because
you know what we really talk about is is
leighton power not only
about the name of the city's electric
system
but it's but it's also about how power
is wielded
and whether anyone can bring you know
light to a situation and
actually let people know what's going on
and
you know the story of cleveland i'm sure
has happened in other places
but i just happened to be the first
person who had an
the opportunity and the time to tell the
story and
that i survived to tell the story it was
cleveland's banking community
that applied heavy pressure on 31 year
old mayor dennis kucinich
to sell the power plant or they wouldn't
refinance the city's
outstanding bond debt what lessons are
there for city officials now who are
dealing with some of these same issues
in their towns and cities
yeah i mean i i think the first thing is
try not to be obligated you know the
campaign finance
puts a lot you know creates a lot of
vulnerability for elected officials
uh you know get elected spent get
elected spending as least amount of
money as you can because you don't
you don't want to have to be obligated
to interest groups and
you know as i write in the book i had
some spiritual guides along the way who
would help
remind me that every minute counts that
what happens in a minute when
everybody's looking or not
that really counts and so i to me
actually and this might sound funny
coming from someone who's in public
office
but you know i was always concerned
about my soul
even more so than winning the next
election because
uh i i actually believe in that that
saying what profit a man if he wins
you know gains a little world and loses
his soul that's i that's what i was
thinking about when
i was in the room with the bankers and
the council president with the banker
and the council president
and they gave me that final ultimatum
about perfect about selling the like
system
hey you know what um i could i couldn't
do it because it wasn't mine to give
away
dennis kucinich i want to thank you so
much for being here a powerful
new book i recommend it to everybody
it's an important part of american
history that we haven't known much about
until you've written this well brian it
means so much to
uh to talk to you and thank you for your
service in cleveland we met in cleveland
many years ago and
uh as an investigative reporter you can
i'm sure you can well understand
the the kind of footnoting that went on
in this book
oh it's great it is well documented in
order to back up everything that said
all right dennis kucinich thank you
again for being here tonight
thank you
coming up next the trump investigation
he calls it a political witch hunt
but the manhattan district attorney is
now subpoenaing witnesses before a grand
jury
and the former president faces serious
legal jeopardy
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
the manhattan district attorney has now
begun to subpoena witnesses for a grand
jury
investigating donald trump the trump
organization
and his alleged shady financial dealings
the former president calls it a
political witch hunt
and predicts that he will soon be back
in power
take back the senate take back the house
we're going to take back the white house
and
sooner than you think it's going to be
really something to get a better
understanding of what could be coming uh
donald trump's way we're joined now by
uh
pulitzer prize-winning investigative
journalist david k johnson david thanks
so much for being here
what do you think is the timetable here
and how bad could it be
for donald trump well now that they have
paneled a special grand jury which
normally has a six-month time period you
know that it's highly
likely it'll be within six months but i
can't imagine they need
that long to present the evidence the
grand jury
and i think it's likely to be very bad
for donald trump
i mentioned on your show last september
that i thought
there's a high chance that donald will
be hit with a new york state
racketeering
charge and john moscow the great
prosecutor agreed with me about that at
the time and you'll now see that
other former prosecutors have come
around to the point i first made
that a racketeering charge is likely
because it allows the government
to upon indictment freeze his assets
and potentially seize those assets
it also is a charge that people can
understand
and it requires finding three underlying
felonies
finding three underlying felonies by
donald trump the trump organization or
members of his family
that's about as far as finding a traffic
light in midtown manhattan
and what are the penalties if found
guilty of that sort of the charge
well the racketeering charge could put
donald in prison for the rest of his
life if a judge were to sentence him to
prison
uh he's likely to be charged under the
martin act with
business records uh misuse
that's a felony that can get you i think
it's 25 years
donald is looking at the prospect upon
conviction
of what amounts to a life sentence
whether or not he would actually go to
prison would be up to a judge
who could well decide that home
confinement would be
sufficient hopefully one would think
home confinement in trump tower not
mar-a-lago given that he's going to be
tried in new york
and what would it mean in terms of the
financial situation for the trump
organization
well one of the things we don't know is
what is the financial situation of the
trump organization
it's a house of cards and donald has
always been
desperate for cash money just runs
through his fingers the way
water does through a hose and
so legal fees alone are going to
just consume uh money from donald trump
on the other hand he's raised several
hundred million dollars by essentially
begging
to the public and well he said the money
was to
overturn the election he's only spent
about nine million dollars on lawyers
for that purpose
so he's got a nest egg he can use for
this of a couple hundred million dollars
and i'm sure there are supporters who
will send him
more money but any first-rate criminal
defense lawyer who's going to take on
this case
knowing donald's history of not paying
his lawyers is probably going to demand
a
very very big fee
from your point of view and we know
donald trump has denied any wrongdoing
and he's called this a political witch
hunt by both the
manhattan district attorney and the new
york state attorney general
from your point of view what would be
the most impressive or effective defense
that he could raise oh on my
my staff i didn't realize what they did
or i mean i just told them
do what the law requires and i can't
believe they went and did these
outrageous things and they never told me
about it
that's not a credible defense but that's
about as solid
offenses he's going to be able to come
up with donald like
several very prominent people on wall
street does not
use email and he speaks not only in code
but through other people
there's a particular uh leader of one of
the hundred biggest companies in america
who talks to an assistant who talks to
assistants
and that's why no prosecutor's ever been
able to get him even though
it's widely understood and there's some
public record indicating he's a major
league criminal
and that's going to be donald's defense
is i i tell these people to push the law
as far as you can
but no further then
i take it that's the importance then of
the district attorney going after his
chief
financial officer mr weissel that's
right and if they file a racketeering
charge that would be against donald
trump
against the trump organization and
people affiliated with it that would
include his three adult children who
were employees of it
and especially allen weiselberg who was
the
quote-unquote chief financial officer
it's not that big an operation
he was the money guy all the way back to
fred trump
can you actually imagine a former
president of the united states being
sent
to prison in a new york state prison for
these crimes
um it would be uh surprising um
i think that a judge would think heavily
about the implications of the country on
the other hand
there are the countries all around the
world that have prosecuted and
imprisoned
former presidents i'm not talking about
dictatorships uh we've seen this in
france uh italy
uh we may momentarily see it in israel
and we've seen it i think once in the
past in israel
there is no reason we should treat the
president
differently uh but that's sort of
textbook level not real world
i would anticipate it is most likely
uh when trump is indicted he will show
up he'll be
uh fingerprinted and identified and
released
uh after all the idea of bail is to make
sure you can't disappear
donald trump can't disappear uh he'd
probably have to give up his passport
however
and upon conviction
most likely home confinement but i would
not be surprised to find out that it's a
lifetime home confinement
amazing if that were to happen and of
course at this point no charges have
been filed against donald trump
david k johnson thank you so much for
joining us this evening
thank you
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media
see if you agree with what the editors
of mediaide had to say about nbc news
anchor
lester holt you're watching brian ross
investigates on the long crime
trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media
as chosen by the editors of mediaite and
we're joined by aidan mclaughlin who is
the editor-in-chief of mediaite which
like the long crime trial network is
part of the dan abrams media empire
and names you've chosen as this week's
winner nbc news anchor
lester holt for his news making
interview with vice president kamala
harris
out the border we've been to the border
we've been to the border you haven't
been to the border
i and i haven't been to europe and i
mean i don't know i don't
understand the point that you're making
i'm not discounting the importance of
the border
and aidan that interview made plenty of
headlines
it did yeah it's been kind of the big
news today now the vice president kamal
harris is down in guatemala
she has been tasked by the white house
to the uh the administration's face
of their response to what's going on
going on at the southern border
she's down in guatemala where she says
that she's addressing the root causes
of migration north uh to the u.s
southern border uh
lester hall the uh nbc nightly news
anchor
asked why she has yet to visit the
border she said we have visited the
border speaking about the administration
he pointed out uh very accurately that
she herself had not visited the border
now you can say that this is sort of a
a partisan uh gotcha uh to note that she
hasn't
gone there yet but uh i think there's no
doubt that that comment from her the
laugh and the comment that she has not
been to europe yet either
is going to be played in republican
attack ads for the next couple years
and lester holt's uh mild tone did not
hide the fact these were tough questions
for the vice president
it's true yeah and you know it was an
accurate point to push on
and we're going to get more segments
from this interview tonight
the rest of it's going to air on nightly
news on nbc and i have no doubt that
we're going to have better you know
more tough questions from lester hall on
top of this one about the border
and then this week's a losers for
another interview stuart farney for his
interview with former president donald
trump
for the presidency in 2024 would you
consider ron desantis governor of
florida as your running mate
sure i would but you know there are
numerous people that are great i would
certainly consider
ron and so why is stuart varney
this week's loser aiden a couple of
reasons actually
the first one requires a little bit of
contest uh back in
january seventh one day after uh the
insurrection at the u.s capitol
stuart varney a fox business anchor went
on the air and said that trump's
presidency had ended in disgrace
and that his political future was over
uh now cut to
uh what four or five months later stuart
barney is interviewing president donald
trump
uh and is asking him who his running
mate is going to be for a potential 2024
run
so it's a pretty staggering reversal
there from stuart barney
also president trump pushed a series of
pretty nuts conspiracy theories about
the election
uh that it was stolen that facebook was
involved in stealing it
george running did not push back at all
uh that is not something that our winner
lester halt would have done
uh stuart varney gets the loser for that
interview with the former president
and mostly for not pushing back on areas
that clearly had much to push back on
i mean when the president former
president united states says that
facebook was involved in stuffing
ballots to steal the 2020 election the
claim
of which one there is no basis for and
two is absolutely absurd on its face
and you don't say anything to correct it
on air that's doing a disservice to your
audience
and uh i mean it's not just not
something that an anchor or a host
should be doing
probably what mr trump did expect though
from fox business
aid mclaughlin thank you so much for
being here thanks the editors of
mediaite for their great choices
and thanks to all of you for watching
tonight and a great big thank you to our
seth a long crime for genius on the air
and off the air
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you